[inaudible].
We're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me as an
author and associate
professor of Philosophy at the
College of William and Mary.
Chris Fryman. Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me. All right man.
We're going to do philosophy for an
hour. Are you ready? Sounds good. Yeah,
you are prepared. I feel the jacket,
shirt combo. It's very philosophy.
Give me the Rubin. That's what this
is my Tyler came up with. All right,
let's talk philosophy because I think one
of the things that I try to do on this
show is I talk about philosophies more
than people, ideas more than people.
And it seems to me we live in a time
where we don't do a lot of philosophy and
ideas stuff. Well, and I guess that's
maybe why, why people are watching this.
So let's do a little philosophy
you want to one with you.
Give me just some of the basics of
what people should understand about
philosophy.
Okay. Well, yeah, that's a great question.
How's that for an open ended question?
Discharge? Uh, yeah, something might
take the hour. But uh, yeah, so I think,
you know, at the fundamental
level philosophy is about
challenging assumptions.
I think one thing that makes philosophy
different from other sorts of academic
disciplines is that you can't
really take anything for granted.
So when you're, you
know, doing philosophy,
you have to justify why killing
people is wrong. For example,
why feeding the hungry is good.
And all of these things that we take for
granted at the level of everyday life
philosophy calls into question.
And I think that's really important.
And so the kinds of philosophical
questions that I'm most
interested in are ones
having to do with moral right
and wrong justice, injustice,
the moral importance of economic equality,
these sorts of things. Uh, and also the,
the ethics of public policy.
So for example,
one thing that non
philosophical disciplines can
do is make predictions about
what a given policy is likely to do.
So we'll opening the borders lead
to higher unemployment, higher GDP,
something like that. Um,
but all things considered,
they can't really tell us what the
right thing to do is. We say, okay,
suppose it turns out that opening
borders will slightly increase domestic
unemployment,
but it also will mean that a certain
workers and the developing world will see
their incomes rise by 300%.
For example,
this leaves open the question
of what should we do?
Is that a trade off that we should make?
And that's really what philosophy
tries to answer is what should we do?
All things considered.
All right,
so in a little bit we're going to get
to some of your moral philosophies that
you care about, an economic
philosophies and, and uh,
immigration and a bunch of other
things in just a little bit. Uh,
but first I'm curious,
what got you interested in
philosophy in the first place?
That's a good question.
Uh,
so I think it was doing philosophy
before I realized I was doing philosophy
because arguing,
let's say good natured arguing was
the family tradition in my household.
So ever since I was a little kid, uh,
you know, my parents and my sister and I,
we would argue about religion and in
these sorts of things, right and wrong,
the economy.
And when I got a little bit older,
I started reading things in
philosophy and economics, columns,
articles and things like that.
And I realized that there was this kind
of formal discipline called philosophy
where you could argue about right
and wrong and justice and injustice.
And if you were very lucky you
could get a job doing this.
If I get paid to do this,
not a lot. Not a lot of jobs,
not paid very much either, but
it's kind of like saying, you know,
you can get paid to eat ice cream for
a living. I thought, okay, that's,
that's a pretty good gig if I can get it.
And so that was kind of the start
of the trajectory into philosophy.
Yeah.
You know,
it's interesting because I came from a
very similar family in that regard where
we argued about everything from economics
and religion and all of those things.
And I guess perhaps if
this is what led you here,
it's kind of what led me here as well.
But we're missing that these days.
Don't you think like that must infuriate
you as someone that cares about ideas.
When you watch the news and
watch all these people that are,
aren't arguing from like a principal
position or something like a,
a philosophically thought out position,
but just from like a party place or
a partisan plays must drive you nuts.
It does. It does because
right. I care about ideas.
I care fundamentally about good arguments.
So this is something that I hope happens
to my students in my classes is they
come in with a set of
preconceptions. They have, you know,
their partisan political beliefs.
Everybody does.
I have my partisan political beliefs,
but I hope we can try as hard as we
can to just focus on the arguments then
critically and maybe change our minds
even if it means admitting that we were
wrong or uh,
you know,
finding out that we have different
political or religious beliefs from our
friends. We should really just follow
wherever the arguments lead us.
I actually like it when you find
out you were wrong on something.
Cause when I've had the
moment on this show and the,
and the most famous one is
when I had Larry elder in here.
And he just kind of beat me senseless
with facts and we've since become friends
and he was on just recently. And I loved
the guy that it was scary in the moment.
Like sitting there in the moment
of being beaten is not fun,
but afterwards when you go,
Whoa, that's what it's about.
It's actually pretty cool.
Yes. So I don't like, like you said in the
moment, I don't like being burdened by,
cause I got a couple of things I'm going
to play pretty good. Nothing was, yeah,
yeah. But, but long term, I think
that's right. It shows growth.
And the funny thing is that what are we
afraid of when it comes to changing our
minds and admitting when we're wrong?
What's really the harm in that?
And I really, I like the process
of arguing it's, you know,
a form of recreation or something,
like a form of exercise. Um, I think,
I think it was Edmund Burke
who said something like,
the person who challenged my
adversary is actually my best friend,
or something like that.
So the person that is willing to argue
with you in good faith and genuinely
cares about getting at what's true rather
than what maybe confirms their prior
political beliefs, that's, you know,
that's the person that I want to hang
out with us. First. I want to talk with
one of my best friends growing
up. Uh, his name is Arie Greek.
So he was willing to Greek
philosophy and all that,
and he was my sparring
partner for them from,
from literally from 12 years old
until, well past college. Even now.
And we ironically, we actually
agree more now than ever before,
which is sort of weird because
we both had sort of reverse, uh,
philosophical journeys
or political journeys,
but that's actually what it's all about.
So tell me a little bit about some of
the philosophers that have affected you.
So one of my favorites is
probably John Stuart Mill.
So he was a classical liberal. He, uh,
so here's what's known as a utilitarian,
and this is a moral theory
that essentially says the
right thing to do is the
thing that has the best consequences.
I think that produces the most
happiness for everybody who's affected.
I find that view attractive and
moral philosophy. But he was also,
he was a classical liberal politically.
Uh, he was a big defender of free speech,
a free discussion in particular.
His book on
Brady is probably the single greatest
defense of freedom of speech.
I travel with it, you know, I'm on
tour right now. I travel with it.
It's a thin book. Everyone should
have it under your pillow. But yeah,
that's about it. Yeah, that's
right. Yeah. So what, okay,
so you mentioned classical liberalism.
Okay. Everyone knows my feelings on this.
Do you see any meaningful distinction
between classical liberalism and
libertarianism at this point?
I think that libertarianism is
probably a bit narrower than classical
liberalism. So, but this
is a matter of debate.
I don't have a very firm opinion on this,
but when I think of a libertarian,
I think of somebody who says the state
should do the following three things,
have a court system,
have police force, um,
and maybe enforced contracts,
something like that, no more,
maybe some kind of very
small social minimum, uh,
Milton Friedman negative
income tax type thing.
Whereas I think classical liberals are
more friendly to a, a more active state.
But I would also say that I'm happy to
say that Libertarians are a part of the
classical liberal family.
Yeah. It's funny because, uh,
I had done Boudreaux and here are a couple
of weeks ago talking about this and I
fall on that path where the more I go down
the libertarian roots, I really liked.
I like that line of thinking. I still
think there's some utility of the state,
but I think the more that you
have these conversations, for me,
I'm finding it harder and harder to
defend anything related to the state.
Which is it,
I guess I'm taking a philosophically fair
approach to this because I'm taking in
new information.
Yeah. Yeah. I, I'm, I'm the
same way. So I think that the,
the best arguments for something like
classical liberalism or libertarianism is
just the pervasiveness of
government failure. So, you know,
you look at where actual government
money goes, not just not in theory,
but in practice where it goes,
um,
what sorts of groups are advantaged
and disadvantaged by the state?
I think that the government
just doesn't work very well.
And so the same reasons why we don't
want the government producing food,
for example,
are also reasons why we might not want
the government and the business of say,
running schools fools.
Right. So do you think it would be
fair to say that if it ran well,
if this thing was a slim operation
and it was financially sensible and we
had people of good moral character in the
government and the rest of it,
but you'd actually have no reason to be
certainly a libertarian and meet perhaps
even a classical liberal,
you might actually be more of some sort
of big government democrat or something
like that. I think that's right. At
least from my perspective. So, as I said,
I'm a fan of mill and utilitarianism.
The idea that the right thing is the
thing that produces the best results.
And so I think in a world in which the
state was run by angels, very wise people,
very benevolent people,
and it produced good results.
I would be happy to accept a,
a big activist government or
regulatory and redistributive state.
But I think that are very powerful
reasons for thinking that that's not the
world that we live in.
So I think that some of my audience,
when they hear you talk about mail
and what's what's best for everyone,
they're going to view that through
some sort of lens of collectivism,
which is going to set some bells off. So
can you unpack that a little bit? Right?
Yeah. So, so for, for what it's worth,
my view is that a system that produces
the most happiness, the most flourishing,
the most prosperity is something
like a libertarian, minimal state,
perhaps with a,
a small social minimum.
So when you look historically
at collectivist regimes,
say the Soviet Union or North
Korea or something like that,
these don't have a good track
record of making people happy.
When you look at the societies that
actually make people happy compared to the
alternatives, they tend to be a
limited government free market,
a civil libertarian ish kind of states.
All right.
So what other philosophers that's
affected you? You're one for one. Yeah,
John Stuart Mill. Right up the top. I'll
give you somebody who you might not like,
although we might not
be familiar with them.
Peter Singer who is a contemporary
utilitarian and a lot of people,
I think a lot of classical
liberals and Libertarians, uh,
aren't big fans of his, although I
think they need not, not be fans of his.
So he's uh,
he's famous for a number of things.
He has a number of very controversial
positions on a lot of things. Um,
but one of his more famous thought
experiments involves you imagining that
you're a walking somewhere and you
pass a small child who's drowning in a
shallow pond and you can save this
child at a very low cost to you all.
All that's required is that you step
into the pond to get your shoes muddy and
pull the child out.
But this means you'll have to spend
that at all 100 bucks on new shoes.
And he says,
clearly the sacrifice of $100 worth
of shoes is worth saving this child.
And so this suggests that we
have strong obligations, uh,
to make personal sacrifices for
the betterment of the world's poor.
And I think that's right, uh, as at the
level of moral principle, for example.
But I think a lot of libertarians and
classical liberals worry that what this is
going to mean is we ought to
have large welfare states.
We ought to have billions of dollars
channeled into foreign aid and so on.
And I can understand why they make that
leap, but I don't think that follows,
especially again,
if you look at the track record of whether
or not the government does a good job
of helping the poor and I think
it generally doesn't. Yeah. So,
and I definitely want to get
to your thoughts on that.
So do you view that sort of is like
that sort of like a micro macro argument
that at a micro level,
yeah, you'd probably do it.
Like I'm sure if either one of
us were walking down the street,
we wouldn't care that much about
our shoes enabled to save somebody.
But at a societal level we'd probably
gets to a lot of your economic arguments
as well. The more that you
keep giving over to society,
the more that it keeps taking in essence
individuals in their private lives.
Uh,
if they do a good job of saying when you
searching which private charities do a
good job of alleviating poverty
in the developing worlds.
And I think there are some,
then we would have in some time in some
sense of societal obligation to help
just in the sense that most people of
means have this obligation to say donate
some of their paycheck to the against
malaria foundation, for example.
But I think that doesn't justify saying
we want the state in the business of
redistributing income,
uh,
on a global level if only because it
just doesn't do a very good job of it and
oftentimes makes poverty even worse.
All right,
so you are a blogger at
bleeding heart libertarian. Yes.
Now I've seen this site before and
I checked it out again before, uh,
before you got here. I thought, all right,
the phrase bleeding heart, libertarians,
that sorta sounds like what a
classical liberal is like, right?
We've got a little,
a little more heart in essence are we
were okay with a little more state to
hopefully make sure that people
who need it the most are okay. Uh,
but I think a lot of people will see
those terms at odds. Bleeding, heart,
libertarian. Yeah. No, and that's
a great, uh, a great point too.
In light of the conversation about Peter
Singer because I do think that we have,
and I think a lot of classical
liberals agree that we have this strong
obligation to uphold political
institutions that work
particularly well for the
poor. And this isn't, even though the
term bleeding heart, libertarians is new.
This isn't just something that popped
up in the last five or six years.
If you go all the way back to Adam Smith,
he has this,
this argument about the division of
Labor and free trade. He says, you know,
you're sitting at your desk trying
to make pins all by yourself.
Maybe you could do two or three in a day.
You have a division of labor where one
person straightened up the wire or the
other person's putting the pin on the,
on the wire and so forth,
makes us massively more productive
than we otherwise could be.
And then through free trade are,
everybody's welfare is increased,
but he stresses that this is particularly
good for the poor because he says a
society in which we're very productive
and we have this abundance of material
goods is a society in which these sorts
of goods are going to be a lot cheaper.
And this is in fact what we see.
Uh,
and so a society in which the real
price of not just necessities,
but also things that we might consider
luxuries like smartphones or something,
a society that makes those abundant and
cheap as a society that's very good for
the poor.
So I think a bleeding heart libertarian
or classical perspective is hundreds of
years old.
Although you probably,
we haven't done a good job of
marketing ourselves, perhaps. Yeah.
How would you actually
define what good is? I mean,
I know that that's a tough
one. That's right. Yeah, that's
a, that's a big question.
So here's the evasive answer is there,
it depends on which philosopher you're
talking to. Right? So, yeah. So,
so some philosophers think that,
so mill has this view that the
could consists of pleasure,
but it's a sophisticated view where some
pleasures are of higher quality than
others. So if, I dunno,
you have pleasure as a result of
shooting up heroin and that's equal in
intensity and duration to the pleasure
that you get from reading Shakespeare.
There's something qualitatively
better about the Shakespeare than,
than the heroin. Um, and so that's his
view is that it's a life of pleasure.
But where are you have these hot, higher
and lower pleasures? Other people,
other utilitarians then, oh, pleasures
created equal. Other people have,
uh, maybe more complicated views where
a bunch of stuff makes a life good.
So it's pleasure,
it's knowledge,
it's living a morally
virtuous life and so on.
And this is a debate that we've been
having for 208 or 2,500 years with no end
in sight. I sense, I know
where you stand on that,
but you want to elaborate on that a little
bit more? Well, so I think that the,
yeah, so it's a good question.
Yeah, no, as long as I'm
here. So what, what is good?
Well, so I think the good for a
particular person is probably, um,
what a philosopher would call the
satisfaction of your informed preferences.
So essentially getting what you want, if
you know what it is that you're getting.
So for example,
you might want the liquid that is in
our glass right now because you have the
belief that it's water.
But if you have the fall,
if that belief is false because it turns
out to be vodka or something like that,
you might have a desire
for what's in there.
But the desire is in some sense
informed by this false belief.
But if you have perfectly true beliefs
about the world and then you desired, uh,
say that cup of water, I said, well
that's good for you to get that water.
You're getting what you want.
Yeah.
So you basically believe
that selfishness is good? No,
because I think that a lot of people,
I think most people in
fact have preferences,
rational preferences for the welfare of
other people. So I would say, you know,
most can you make it a
selfish argument for that?
Because the way I've
always sort of understand,
or at least the way I use these words
now is that by doing what is good for me,
I, that doesn't mean I want to
ransack the entire world, right?
I want to do good so that
it's good for my community.
I want to take care of my own
house so that my neighbor,
hopefully it will be like I,
I'm next door to someone with a nice
house and you're going to take care of
their eyes.
So I view selfish.
I guess that's a little more of an
ran thing where I've used selfishness
actually as a virtue.
Yeah.
So I think the difference would be in
at say a case where you're, you're, uh,
walking and see the child drowning in
the shallow pond, the question would be,
well, what is the reason why you're saving
this child and, and ruining your boots?
I think a good answer to that as well,
because they care about
the child's welfare. Um,
and then sometimes it's true that
that's a preference that you have.
So it's your preference until you
could call it a sort of, I don't know,
self guided or self preference,
but I wouldn't call it a
selfish preference in the
sense that you expect in some
sense,
uh,
this child's welfare to directly
translate into benefits for you. Right.
But you would feel good after I get it.
Like you wouldn't if you'd be a pretty
twisted person if you were like, well,
walking by like, well, how's that gonna
make me feel after low, you should,
you should do what to write.
But I know what's right can often
lead to all sorts of bad things. Um,
but I think you could make a selfish
argument for that. Like, you know,
that if you walk by a child that
you could easily help and you don't,
you're going to feel shitty after if you
have any shred of conscious. Well, right.
So I hope,
right.
[inaudible] sociopaths I hope have
that have that sort of psychological
disposition.
And as far as sort of ones.
So I think also what morality is more
concerned with is not just the good of the
individual,
but sort of the good of all.
So I think sort of what the morally
right thing to do is figuring out that
decision.
So this is the kind of million utilitarian
view that the right thing to do is
basically that which produces
the most good for everybody,
not just an individual person. So
it could be in some cases that, uh,
a person's individual good, uh,
comes apart from what's morally good.
So you could imagine somebody who just
has no desire to help other people.
I would still say they're doing something
morally wrong if they fell to help
other people because they're not taking
that person's welfare into account.
Right.
So where do you think morals come from?
This has been an ongoing discussion
on this show between, you know,
talking to Jordan Peters and adventure
peer and Sam Harris and Michael Shermer,
Dennis Prager, and many others. And
there's sort of a religious argument.
I think there's a secular argument for it.
Um,
I think I'm somewhere in the middle.
I think it's a really rich spot to figure
out what people think about things.
Yeah. So that's, that's a,
that's a hard question. Uh,
I'm not sure I have a
satisfying answer to that,
but maybe in terms of
the religious question,
there's this very old argument from
Plato at the Youth of flow dilemma.
I'm not sure if that's ever popped up in
conversation, but the idea is basically,
uh,
does,
does God wills something because it's
pious independently of God's will or is it
pious because God wills it and
Plato's view was, well, uh, it,
it doesn't quite make sense to say that
it's pious just because God wills it.
Because you could imagine as a thought
experiment that God willing all sorts of
terrible things just as, as a
thought experiment that, you know,
if God wills us to torture it doesn't
seem like that would make torture good.
Um, and so it seems more
plausible to think that, uh,
there is sort of an independent
standard of goodness. Even,
even if you are a theist,
for example,
and you believe in God and you believe
God has this intimate connection to
morality, I think even on views like
that, it makes sense to say that, um,
goodness is in some sense
independent of the will of God.
And so in terms of what more,
that's again, sort of an
evasive answer as to what,
it's not a, where morality comes from.
I mean, I'm inclined to say, I mean,
it comes from sort of what's good for
human beings and maybe other sentient
animals. So what sorts of things satisfy
or interest satisfy our preferences,
causes us pleasure and pain,
these sorts of things.
Do you think that subjective though,
that different cultures obviously have
different beliefs in different, you know,
moralities and all sorts of things?
I would say it is not subjective
in the, in the sense that, uh,
different,
different cultures having different moral
beliefs would show that nobody's wrong
in those debates. So it might be very
difficult to determine who is wrong,
but I don't think the mere fact that
different cultures have moral standards
shows that it's subjective.
So by analogy, uh,
you could imagine different cultures
having different beliefs about astrology,
for example.
So some cultures think that astrology
is legitimate enterprise are the ones,
don't they disagree about that?
But I think it's safe to say that there
is in some sense and objectively correct
answer about that. Uh, same thing with
other sorts of scientific disputes. Right?
But do you think that
that objective place,
does that have to come from God per
say? Or can it come from, I mean, the,
the discussion that we've had a lot around
here and that a lot of people in this
space talk about basically
is does objective morality
either come from God and
religion or does it come
from enlightenment values?
And then there's other arguments that
it's only through religion that we got to
enlightenment values in the first.
Yeah,
that's tough.
My hunch is that something like
enlightenment values. Um, so I,
I don't know, I'm somewhere in the
agnostic space, uh, myself. Uh,
and so I think that sort of philosophy
guy, right, exactly. So it's hard not to,
it's, it's hard not to be an
agnostic. So yeah. So I'm agnostic,
but I'm also Jewish. And so there's,
it's all part of the kind of questioning,
lack of certainty and so forth.
Um,
so I think that there is that there's
enough reason to think that we have
objective morality, even if you're not
certain about the existence of God. Um,
that,
yeah,
we shouldn't worry that morality is going
to collapse if people become atheist
and agnostic.
Right? Because when I've
had this discussion, usually
with conservatives, you know,
they love to say, well, God gave
us morality. You know what I mean?
Your rights come from God. And for
me it's like, I think you have,
whether they're god,
the God given rights,
or it's your right freedom is your right
as a human being or as optimus prime
said, freedom is the right of all
sentient beings. You don't even like,
I think you are born free.
I just think that's a,
that's a humanistic approach
or you're born free.
The government can take away your freedom,
but it doesn't give it to you.
And I think that's just a
really interesting place to
go for all these political
discussions.
I agree.
So I that that's what I think that there
are no right and wrong ways to treat
other human beings that are just true
independently of whether or not the state
happens to respect them. And as soon
as the kind of enlightenment thought,
so John Locke's,
I'd look in the state of nature,
I would be wrong to kill you or
assault you or steal your property.
This is just the wrong
way to treat human beings.
It doesn't really have
anything to do with the state.
Now he might want the state to
come in and protect those rights,
enforce those rights and so on.
But the rights of themselves,
the standard of the right and wrong way
to treat other people does not itself
come from the state. So before
we get into some of your, your,
the specific arguments that you
make on economics into a budget,
how do you think are our founders
got so much of this stuff right?
If I'm going on the assumption
you believe they did,
but I mean every time I go to DC and I
go to the monuments and I read all of
this stuff and I just
was in Philly yesterday,
I mentioned to you and I have now
a copy of the I that little copy,
like an old Republican senator of the
declaration and the Declaration of
independence had gone off the alarm at
the, there was this thing with like,
it would set off the Tsa alarms at
the, Oh, this one's just standard,
simple paper or whatever. It's probably,
we'll set up some alarm somewhere.
I'm sure. Um, if I go to San Francisco
or something, I'm sure a constitution,
it would set off an alarm. But, um, uh,
I assume you think that they got
a much of this stuff correctly.
How do you think they, they did it?
Yeah, so I think that, I don't know.
So I think that some of it,
and this is a bit outside of my own area,
but I think that a lot of them were
influenced by a smart philosophers.
People like,
so I think the law,
the influence of someone like lock on
the constitution is pretty evident.
The influence of somebody like David
Hume on, uh, people like, uh, Madison.
I think that's, I think that maybe that's
a matter of controversy and history,
but I think there's some
evidence to suggest that.
So I think that they were students
of history students, a philosophy,
students of economics, and this helped
them get a lot. Right. And I think I,
you know,
obviously I think there were mistakes
and the way that they applied it and, um,
you know, the way that,
uh, like Jefferson's, uh,
omission of mentions of
slavery and things like that.
But I think in terms of
like the fundamentals,
a lot of that was informed by really
smart philosophers and economists.